this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode three with daryl cooper and me
jocko willink let's keep going
i know where i want to pick up if you
have somewhere go you can go first
i want to know what little jocko little
semen recruit will inc
who joined in 1990 you you uh taught us
last week
last episode you come into the you come
into the seal teams in the 1990s
and uh if you're a warrior looking for a
war the 90s are a little bit of a dead
zone
well you got to remember partially
accurate
but as we already talked about warrior
looking for
a war in the delayed entry program
through the summer of 1990
as this buildup is happening i'm
thinking
i'm gonna get exactly what i asked for
and i
am super pumped about that
uh you know i'm i'm ready to rock and
roll i think that this and like i said i
i
on one of the earlier podcasts i thought
there was there were reports there was
40 000
40 000 casualties in the first 48 hours
and i'm like oh yeah
they're gonna need me they're gonna need
me to help win this bad boy
because i'm young and dumb and ready to
rock and roll
so then when it was over then then i'm
in buds and it's over
in buds and it's over so now i'm
thinking
okay what's what's gonna happen and you
know
showed up and then it was peace time
peacetime teams
which is not not what you dream about
when you're
when you're a young lad going in the
teams going through
seal training you think you're just
going to war and i
i was dumb and so i was checking into
seal team one and i thought they were
going to send me to vietnam
like evil the gulf war is over but
that's okay seals were sneaking around
the world doing stuff everywhere
you know that's just not true just not
true it's it is kind of true now
right in fact i'll go and say it is true
now like there are things happening
around the world all the time that's the
way it is now
that's post september 11th pre september
11th
there was there was years you know i
knew guys
that were master chiefs that were in the
seal teams
for 30 years you know they came in in
and retired in 19 or 2001 and they never
fired a shot in anger so yeah the 90s
was
was not was not
good from a perspective of wanting to go
to war and look man i'm sorry
everybody that
that that's what i wanted to do with my
life i i don't know what to tell you
i guess let's be happy that i didn't
want to be a criminal or i didn't want
to be a gangster or i didn't want to be
a murderer i wanted to be a seal and i
want to go to war that's the way it was
and
i'm sorry that that's the way it is but
that's the way it is and i can tell you
that with something else i'm not alone
he's not that sorry yeah and he and i'm
not alone there's
all kinds of young men and i don't know
where we get it from
i don't know where it comes from it's
part of our instinct
is to is to fight wars to tell you where
it comes from is
when you look at people like al qaeda
and iraq who ended up taking over
large sections of the country in 2004
five
and six who do you want to send after
them
you know people have this idea that the
american military because it's so
technologically advanced
and we've got all this just access to so
many tools and toys that other people
don't have that
um that our soldiers are sort of like
skilled labor
and that's not it's not it's not how it
works you know you need people who are
gonna go in
you know unless you're unless you're
sort of itching for the fight
um you're not gonna be ready to handle
handle
the kind of thing that you guys had to
deal with over there yeah and
it is weird though to think that there's
a bunch of people
that there that that want to go fight
like that's a weird
if if you think about it you know from a
basic human instinct right
is survival right the
self-preservation that's a basic human
instinct the last
job you would sign up for with that
instinct is
i'm going to be some kind of a soldier i
would go to war so it's a little bit
tricky to
understand it's a little bit tricky to
understand
uh and even if you go even you say well
you know people fight right like you
know you go out on a friday night in
downtown wherever there's gonna be some
fights
and that's the way it is but and i guess
you know out of those
out of those fights that break out some
of those people are going out looking
for fights just a human instinct and i
think you take that to the next level
and you got people like me
that that want to go to war and
again like it's knowing what i now know
about war and
understanding it at a deeper level i i
do say hey i'm sorry that's the way it
is
but it's also i'm sorry that that's the
reality
and i'm not gonna lie about it i'm not
going to tell you uh
you know when when 9 11 happened there
wasn't a giant part of me
that was saying oh cool now i get to go
fight
you know oh yeah it's tragic and
horrible and how dare they but
someone's gonna have to avenge this and
thank god
that someone is me and my friends so
well that
i want to ask you about that part so
this drive to go to go to war
i do wonder if some part of it for
people is they have an intuition
that um you know people love their
friends
they got really great friends and those
friendships were usually
made great uh during the most difficult
times
of those people's lives the guys who
were there for them you know through a
difficult breakup or whatever it was
those are the times when those
friendships get
forged and i think maybe people have an
intuition that
when you enter into a human experience
with that level of intensity something
like war
it's really not it's a level of intense
human experience it's not really
accessible to most people
in in any way in their normal life
unless they're a criminal
um that you're going to
experience that for you was it that you
wanted to go to war was there some part
of you that like
you were going to go to war with your
friends and you were going to be part of
this thing with
other people we appreciate you throwing
out some
nice little bait softball thing to make
me sound like i had this altruistic
thing of going to war with my friends
and
way before i had any friends you know in
the military
i still had that feeling all right
that's the last time i'll pander to you
man
i appreciate it i appreciate you trying
to look trying to make me look like a
good human
but hey man let's face it
there's there's there's a group of
humans
that have i mean every person has
some sort of natural proclivity towards
something right and i've said this
before
when when when some people are walking
around
as a 10 year old and they see a a
businessman in a suit with a briefcase
they think that looks cool like they
think that guy's got power that looks
cool
they see someone else they see the
firemen and they go that looks cool i
want to do that
they see an astronaut they go i want to
fly into space or they see uh
whatever you name the occupation and
there's people and you know
at echelon front i work with people that
love doing their job like that's what
they love doing you love your job
right that's what you love doing it's
like okay cool
guess what um my natural thing was i
really wanted to
do this job and
you weren't going to be a model so i
definitely wasn't going to be a model
and and and you know i i don't
know that i really would have been
so um
i wouldn't have been so con i don't know
that i could have been as committed as i
was
to anything else i can't imagine trying
to
tr trying to to have some other job that
i
would have been this committed to now i
learned
through the military and through the
seal teams that commitment was a good
thing
and that i could kind of fake commitment
like i
think when i went to college the navy
sent me to college from
2000 and from 2000 to 2003
and when i when i went to college i
faked that i was into it and i did
really well why because i made it my job
and i guess that was still tied into you
know well i guess no i guess i was going
to say it's tied into steel
so that was just a lot of it that was
just ego i'm going to be number one
that's me i'm going to make this happen
part of it was ego
versus the the professors oh you think
you're smart cool
you give me any ask me any question
about your little test
and i'm gonna know it and that's that's
what i that was the attitude i made it
into a game
i boost my ego driven by ego and you
know that's not a bad thing right
i'm not saying it was my ego and i
should have put no no no my ego helped
me
do well in college i didn't want to get
shown up by a professor i wanted to
be to to to to go to battle with my
professors and win
you know so that's what i did and so
there are some false starts in the 90s i
think i remember you saying before that
you were on a ship off the coast of
africa while rwanda
was going on in 1994. yep and so there
might have been some times where you
thought maybe this is
yeah well that made this and prior to
that somalia i was sitting off the coast
of somalia
that same deployment we had our gear
loaded it's the first time i loaded out
like we loaded out our weapons
loaded out our gear had our web gear
filled with ammo and grenades and
you know we were ready on that one is it
93 this was in or
this was in 94. okay 94. so i forget
what had happened but there was you know
something was going on in somalia
and this is after we had pulled out it
was yeah or maybe we were in the process
i think we were in the process
but whatever had spun up it spun up
and obvious it's actually surprising if
you would ask me this pre-911 i would
have told you the entire
the entire enemy order of battle i would
have known everything and it was just
because that was one time yeah my whole
and now i can't
i literally can't even remember right
now what was happening you know and if
it wasn't for rwanda being this massive
genocide
i probably wouldn't remember that either
because we were spun up to go on that
one
and we didn't go and do anything and you
are just
spending that decade just sharpening the
edge
and then tuesday morning 9 30 or so in
the morning
i guess it was i was on the east coast i
was actually just over by arlington at
the time when it happened
it would have been early in the morning
here but you get up at 4 30 so you would
have
been aware 9 11 happens
and not only are we going to war but you
are being fed an enemy
that it's not a lot of ambiguity here
this guy's flying planes into civilian
buildings
um you're not being asked to go invade
vietnam
for maybe a reason that half the country
doesn't understand this is a this is a
bad guy
and you're what's your rank at this
point what are you in 2001
in 2001 i'm a lieutenant junior grade so
i had been commissioned i got
commissioned in
1998 i did a tour at seal team two
and at seal team two i promoted from
ensign to lieutenant junior grade
and i promoted to lieutenant junior
grade it was
like the day i left so i was i was only
at till team two for two years
and then lieutenant junior grade and
then the navy sent me to college i
hadn't been to college yet
and then while i was in college i
automatically made
lieutenant but i hadn't made lieutenant
yet so yeah i was a lieutenant junior
grade
going to college and so your
911 happens and you're a seal officer
and you're ready to roll
you've been sharpening the edge for 10
years almost
or i guess it would have been about 10
years at that point and uh
do you have in your head the first gulf
war a little bit like this thing's gonna
be over before i get honestly
worried absolutely scared that i'm gonna
miss it
i called the officer detailer who was a
friend of mine who
um i said hey you know sir
pull me out of cause i was in college i
still had two more years of college left
like it was i was graduating in 2003
and i said and this is a nightmare for
me this is a nightmare
so you don't want to be one of the seals
who didn't ugh who doesn't have any
combat when everybody else goes
it's a nightmare and so i call this the
seal detailer who's
who's a friend of mine i had worked for
him he was a great guy
and i said sir please just get me out of
school i'll get my degree online i have
no reason to be here i can go
i you know i'm ready and he said
and i this was in afghanistan or when
iraq was coming up
this was like september 12th right right
okay so you want to go to afghanistan or
wherever wherever we're going
i'm in like you you could have told me
we were invading didn't matter you could
have told me you were invading
sorry denmark yeah denmark whatever i
bring it i'm ready to rock and roll
um and
which which is interesting because i'm
i'm saying these remarks
like about how excited and fired up and
motivated and
and and dumb i was and that's why we
have
leadership you know that's why we have
leadership we have leadership and that's
why
i became a leader and
as a leader like that's what makes the
military work
you got guys that are ready to chomping
at the bit
right and sometimes you guys got people
that aren't chomping at the bit
and and what you have to do as leaders
you have to find the balance you have to
get people if they're not trumpet
but you got to push them if they're
chomping at the bit you got to pull in
the reins you know
and i'm going to tell you right now it's
much easier to have guys that you have
to pull in the reins on and i almost
always i almost always produced
guys that i had to pull the reins on i
reinforced behavior that was
aggressive that's what i did so all i
had to do was pull the reins because
that's a much easier
job it's a much easier job so that's the
way i set myself up that's the that's
the culture that i
produced if you worked for me i would
i was pulling the reins on you and
people that people that needed to be
pushed
they weren't really front runners for me
and they probably
would find themselves in different
situations
so what i'm saying it's interesting you
know what i'm telling you like look i
would have invaded denmark if they put
the target on denmark i will go
you know we're joking about that but
that's what you have to think about you
know when you're in a leadership
position that's what you've got
and especially pre-911 this early phase
of the war
everybody was worried and so this is
this is the interesting so i called my
detail
and said hey boss please send me to a
team i'll go to any team i'll take any
job
and he says to me jaco this war is going
to last a long time
and i didn't believe him and i don't
even know if he believed himself
because all the lessons that you you
know that you
talked about that we learned
unfortunately hey
we can kick their ass really quickly
they're not they're not a formidable
enemy blah blah blah
i i believe that and i'm sure he must
have had some sense of that
maybe his sense was that this was a
going to be a broader
longer kind of global low-intensity
conflict and there would be
plenty of time for me to do an operation
here
or an operation there because back in
those days
i spent most of my career training for
and
operation like if you were lucky you did
a
singular real mission like
like i would have done in somalia like i
would have done in
in rwanda had they given us the go
one mission and i would have been
totally happy and so i think in his mind
now that i'm reflecting on it he was
probably thinking
hey this is gonna be a long global war
it'll last a long time
we'll be striking targets for the next
20 years or that
probably the next next three or four
years we'll be striking these kind of
terrorist targets around the world
that's probably what he was thinking the
other interesting thing about this is
is i was talking to him him actually i
saw him and his wife
a few months ago several months ago
actually
and i was talking about hey i remember
when i called you after september 11th
and he said
he said yeah everyone called me so so
the reality is yeah jockle was fired up
so is every other seal that was not a
seal team
was calling trying to get to a seal team
well 97
of the seals that weren't at a single
team or maybe ninety percent
were that that were they wanted to go
they wanted to go get in there
seals had to rework their mission i
imagine i mean you guys are you go to
afghanistan you're doing mountain
warfare
um maybe doing some of the higher risk
missions but
semi-conventional missions a lot of the
time right well the you want to talk
about reworking your mission
well i had
never done
any type of vehicle assault
until about maybe a month before
we left for iraq the only time we would
use vehicles
we would call them helo trucks because
it was to simulate a helicopter
because you can't always get helicopters
for your training evolutions
so we would get in the back of us you
know of a six ton or whatever
and uh or a six by and and drive up to a
target area and get out and pretend we
just got out of a helicopter
we didn't look at it it never even made
sense to us that was like a viable
combat system a humvee
and it's actually kind of crazy because
it's not just i can tell you right now
and any
any seal that says anything different
would be full of shit
you know there was we had these this
this
uh vehicle called a dpv a desert patrol
vehicle which was like those old dune
bugs it was a dune buggy looking thing
and like that was kind of a thing but it
was
almost like that was this little
specialized thing where if you were
gonna do a reconnaissance
in the desert very specific you might
use one of those there was no way we
were thinking hey
a a sealed assault force
rolling down you know downtown baghdad
in vehicles we just didn't think of it
we just didn't think of it
and really our urban combat combat
i would say our urban our assessment
of urban combat not our assessment but
our our idea that we would be engaged in
these
like hey we're going to be an urban
which is totally ignorant if you think
about i mean it's just totally ignorant
i mean we would go out and train let me
put it this way we'd go out and train
for a month in the desert we go
train for a month in the jungle we train
for three weeks in the mountains we go
for a week
in the urban environment like we just
didn't
put it together even the the somalia
experience in 93 didn't really
change that at all not as much as it
should have not as much as it should
have it should have been
an eye opener but
you know what you know what that was
that was one mission
so there's plenty of you know just like
i said you're training for one mission
that was one mission and it's like oh
well that kind of mission
probably won't happen again that was a
little little chance
encounter that happened to be in a city
you know where
we are going to be ready for these
desert patrols
foot patrols so
our our
attitude had to shift very very quickly
and it did
and and one of the best things about the
seal teams
is one of our strengths one of our
weaknesses is that we don't have
doctrine or we didn't we
we have doctor now we didn't have
doctrine and so when we would do
when we would do one of these desert um
raids on a desert target in training
no one would tell us exactly how to do
it we kind of figured stuff out and
it got passed down through oral history
and so we we didn't have a lot of
doctrine and
we therefore when missions changed for
us we could
we we still knew how to figure things
out that was that was the biggest
strength we had
was we could be in a situation and go
okay
here's here's the adjustments we need to
make how do we make these adjustments
and we can make them you and it seems
like you guys probably had
the expectation of being given a task
and you've got to figure out how to go
accomplish that task rather than kind of
being told
you're part of the war yeah and you're
going to be handed some
extra high-risk you know high-value
missions and so forth but you're just
part of the war
and um you know your detailer told you
to hang on that you'd be getting some
action little did you know that
uh the civilians up top of the dod and
everywhere else were
cooking something up for you yeah
because we and
i guess i guess it became very evident
very quickly that
we were going to go into afghanistan and
so
that kicked off and
that that kicked off very very quickly
yeah you know very very quickly you know
i think we had
we had troops in there by october
october yeah pretty remarkable how
quickly we were able to get people in
there with the northern alliance and
start working on yeah
but it was the same day that the planes
at the towers in the pentagon
uh that people started talking about
iraq in the defense department in in the
white house
paul wolfowitz and rumsfeld they were
the ones pushing it
early and it was that day they started
talking about is there a way to connect
iraq with this
um they had their own reasons that we
talked about the last episode for
wanting that guy out of there
um there probably weren't a lot of ways
to connect saddam hussein
so you're kind of you're kind of
implying
that they're looking to make a
connection
almost you're almost implying that it
was in a in a disingenuous way
i think that or let me ask you is are
you implying that it was a disingenuous
so i think that some of the civilians
at the high level specifically wolf
woods and rumsfeld
cheney to a degree that they believed
there were good reasons to take out
saddam hussein and go in there and do
this
and that this provided them an
opportunity to do it yeah
i do think that so so i would agree okay
now that you've kind of
taken taken that little nuanced
adjustment
for me i would i would say their
assessment was
what we want is greater stability and
we want better security and we don't
want any of these areas where
these kind of people can fester and grow
we're here we're looking at afghanistan
let's look at iraq too
you know and sure now now you
you take that attitude and then you
overlay that
on top of hey this is the asshole that
you know
did all these things in the gulf war
this is the guy that tried to kill my
dad
like all these things you overlay that
and now i you know
i i i get it what do we learn from
what happened in afghanistan we learned
that you can't have
big swaths of territory that aren't
under the firm control of states
right because there's nobody to hold
responsible for what goes on there
and um they become these festering
swords where do we have problems
somalia afghanistan
mexico in a different way you know they
don't so much
you know not international terror or
anything but there's large swaths of
groups that are pretty nasty
down there controlling large swastika
territory
and we kind of decided that that's not
acceptable anymore to just have these
areas that are not really under
anybody's control or even worse
are a state that is willing to ally
itself with
terrorists i think they made some
tenuous and disingenuous connections to
saddam hussein i do think that
and then i think that there's been
people from the cia
and other places who've come out and
said that there were some people in the
administration
who you know we would tell them here's
one side of the story but here's the
other side of the story and they would
just ignore
the other side of the story and as part
of that is just like you know
confirmation biases and the right nine
yards and
and and that yes this is where
you know we started touching on this
subject earlier this is where
as a leader as a decision maker you ha
you oh you have to take the time and do
the whole do the mental homework
to really and truly try and understand
what the other side of the argument is
and you know you talked about this when
you came on my podcast you talked about
the fact that you
when you when you put the podcast
together
you want to your kind of bar that you're
trying to set for yourself is that you
can empathize with both sides of an
argument
and that is a very important tool to
have as a leader
to not just look at the other side of
the argument and say they're wrong they
don't get it they don't make any sense
that that is not the right thing to do
and in fact whenever you know as a
leader when you present to me a plan
or when i when you come to me and you
say hey here's how i want to solve this
problem or here's what i think about
this
and i have a different opinion my
immediate reaction is okay how is he
right
that's my my immediate reaction isn't
isn't how is daryl wrong my immediate
reaction is
how is he right how is he seeing this
how can i be wrong
that's my immediate reaction so when we
yeah when i hear reports like that
that that the attitude is here's what we
think
you come in here with your opinion and
i'm just gonna disregard it
because i know better that's an awful
it's arrogance it's ego
and it'll drive to bad decision-making
yeah i think that there were people
in the civilian power structure
who uh you know they were at mid and
junior levels in those same in the same
power structure at the dod and other
places during the first gulf war
they felt a lot of guilt um over
the fact that we had told the shia and
the kurds encouraged them to rise up and
then
stood aside while saddam butchered them
and they felt that we
that we besmirched ourselves a little
bit by doing that and then we should
have taken that guy out then
um what i uh what i what i
resent about the way that they handled
it early on was i feel like i think that
they didn't trust the american people
enough
to give them the story straight
rather than laying everything out and
saying look here's the strategic
situation
here's why we can't let this guy stay
here anymore
here's the you know for regional
stability reasons
for um humanitarian humanitarian reasons
just lay it all out
and let the american people make a
decision about that
instead they kind of gambled on a few
things now i'll give them like
by all accounts they all believed that
he had
stockpiles of wmd everywhere right and
if that was the case he's a guy who's
perfectly willing to use those in
irrational wildly irrational ways so if
he had him that's a very dangerous thing
by all accounts these people weren't
lying about that you know they weren't
making it up
they expected to find them they were
surprised when we didn't find them
everywhere
um i wish that they had not
rolled the dice on making that the uh
the front line of their argument
for sure and you know this is this comes
up all the time you got to tell people
the truth about what's happening
and when you tell people the truth about
what's happening
then that
that that will have the ultimate
positive
um result now and and to take that a
little bit further
when you are telling people the truth
that means you also tell them the truth
about things that you don't know
100 because when you say
listen we really think well this is
going to keep this is going to help
stability we can't have these areas
where
al qaeda could train if they get pushed
out of afghanistan they can easily come
here we can't allow that to happen
this is an unstable region by the way
and also there's a strong possibility
that there could be
weapons of mass destruction there so do
we know any of these things 100 no of
course not
this is what we're thinking and when you
instead
when you go out there on a limb and you
you know it's beyond just putting your
all your eggs in one basket because
that's
one problem but then the problem was the
level of certitude that they gave
was because they were trying to sell it
yeah it came across with a lot of
certitude
and you know look man when you look at
those overhead pictures and
you see you see condoleezza rice and and
general powell these you know highly
respected people in the united nations
and the united
nations are all nodding their head in
agreement hey man
that's a and like we talked about
earlier this is a this is coming from
people in saddam's own people that are
saying
yes of course he has these things yes
yes he has them right
even with all that you got to give
yourself an
out as a leader and the way you give
yourself an hour as a leader
is by not being so egotistical and
arrogant that you
know something 100 you know how many
things i know 100
like almost nothing there's almost
nothing that i know
100 and i will never look very rarely
will you catch me
saying this is the fact i just not gonna
say that
you don't have an out and you lose trust
and confidence with people
when you when you express yourself that
way so
i always joke with people i say if i
ever tell you something like 100
if i ever say darryl this is what you
need to do
100 i'm telling you this then you should
probably do it yeah
because i will not you probably
likely will never hear me say anything
like that so
those are some mistakes that i i think
compound
the the mistake that you're talking
about there was an element
within some of the brass up in the
civilian leadership um
who it you know these this is this is
from stories that have come out since
then
as people have reported it including
people on the inside that the decision
that we were going after iraq it wasn't
a debate what are we going to do
we got hit on 911 we got to do something
about afghanistan
where else are our threats that there
were some people in there in powerful
places
who made the decision we're going into
iraq
and we're going to figure out how to tie
this thing in and sell it
what's that book by was it bob woodward
woodward's got one
and which one what's this one on that
one um
my favorite one on the early period up
until about 05 is fiasco by tom rix yeah
see i'm
i should have reviewed because you know
i'm trying to think through these things
and i haven't thought about them for a
long long long time
you know so i'm trying to i'm trying to
think through you know
what what like like these players
because there certainly were players and
um a lot of them were there in the first
gulf war and we talked about before
uh you know one of the one of the things
that happened after the gulf war is the
military people
uh the generals in the first gulf war
including
general powell who's now the secretary
of state who's now quite skeptical
of the idea of going into iraq he agrees
to go to the u.n
and provide his lend his credibility to
the to to the salesmanship but
um he was worried about it and he was
he was counseling caution well he was
doing that in the first gulf war too
he was you know the generals at the time
were saying we want
six carrier strike groups we want
overwhelming force because they were
vietnam guys and they didn't want to get
bogged down into a quagmire
and a lot of the civilians who were
there at the time
in the defense department and the rest
of this the power structure were there
in the bush administration 03 and
they're hearing the same thing again
from the military a lot of the military
brass is like wait a second here
you want to do what they're a little
more hesitant and the civilians
wolfowitz and them are like yeah yeah
okay we've heard this before we just
it's just this is just how you guys are
apparently
and since then they had watched us just
take apart the iraqis in the first in in
the gulf war
use basically air power and some you
know
some patrols in kosovo to achieve a
pretty you know pretty good result there
um and so now and now we're in
afghanistan
and that hasn't dragged on for 19 years
yet we're just a couple years into that
one and so we're thinking
you know i think there were some people
who were a little bit blase about it
because they had the idea that at this
point there's nothing that the american
military can't do
yeah that there's just nothing it can't
do when uh when the um
kosovo thing was happening it kicked off
and we and i was at seal team 2 at the
time
and we started dropping bombs and it
like hit the new i forget the timing of
it
but the timing of it played out that
it had kind of kicked off and maybe it
you know in the afternoon or something
and
overnight you know we wake up in the
morning and there's the bombs being
dropped and we show up to work and
at steel team two we have quarters and
we're so we're all standing there
and and you know there's a couple basic
announcements that come out
you know and then i'm not kidding like
one of the admin
girls gets up and is like hey we're
having the potluck
dinner on whatever so it's gonna start
at this time
you know families are invited or
whatever and then one of my buddies
um says something along the lines of it
was kind of like one of those moments
where
you know the young i think he was an e6
at the time but you know
barks out hey everyone potluck dinner
aside
each we should we're at war right now
you know and i was kind of i always
laughed about that because
even that you know we started dropping
these bombs and everything
it was really really distant and again
this is coming from me all amped up
hoping to go to war praying for
blah blah blah and the war a little war
started
and everyone's kind of like oh whatever
you know we're gonna drop some bombs you
know
uh it's it seems so regional and so
small
and and potluck dinner aside you know
we're at war right now and
what was it 86 day bombing campaign or
something yeah about that
some certain number of days very
very uh effective bombing and
you know the first time that we kind of
looked around and said
hey maybe we don't need to put boots on
the ground to to win
which no one ever said that any and
even after that you know going into the
going into iraq it was like oh you gotta
have to put boots on the ground
still would hear that but i'm sure some
people are going really and even the
ground forces that the
coalition did commit in kosovo they were
just driving around showing presents
yeah you know i um one of my uh one of
my friends was in the army said that
some
some of the people took calling it
dabbing driving around
and and yeah so
you get up to 2003 and um
we're going into iraq that decision has
been made around the summer of 2002.
it's a matter of selling it to the
people selling it to
which allies of ours we could we get
into early 2003 and there are
global protests largest protests in
history as far as i know 30 million
people
participated massive 168 million people
on
february 15th or so much of which by the
way was
you know you would think something like
that would be a global event i think
most people just
unless they were participating or you
know knew somebody who knew somebody
they were like there were some protests
but the idea that there were these giant
protests i think most people that
passed right by a lot of yeah i don't
even remember anything about that
um i kind of remember it i remember you
know as a
three-minute news story somewhere that's
about it
and we end up going into iraq
largely because this is what rumsfeld
wanted to do and let me just jump in
real quick yeah
because i was going to bring this to
present day what's happening something
happened right now with the covid
uh virus what you just said
right this is very standard when a
war scenario starts to unfold
that you are going to get one half
roughly of the population even after
september 11th you know
okay what 80 percent of the population
after 9 11 said afghanistan they had
something to do with it cool go get them
by the time we fast forward two years
now we're looking at iraq
and you got at least half the population
going
i don't know and what's interesting
about what's unfolding right now is
march
uh it is march 25th 2020 we're like
in the in the middle of this covid
virus thing the country's shut down you
know
not allowed to go out of our houses in
california
new york is you know under serious
pressure so
the whole country the economy is at a
standstill
that's where we're at right now well
when you go to war with iraq where you
go to war with afghanistan or you go to
war with anybody
there's a whole group of americans that
raise their hand and say no
and it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
what the
what the what the cause is yeah you know
even when we're going to take out isis
you know it just has to do with their
own self contagion
war is just never good and so you get
some level of resistance against
the government right there's some level
of public outcry against the
governmental decisions
and what's been interesting about this
and and i think it's turning a corner
right now
is the this virus war
there's no resistance there's no there's
like no and
i'm starting to see it now but basically
everything it's total war
if we need to shut down the government
if we need to shut down the economy
it doesn't matter this is all bad and
look i don't know whether that's the
right decision or
not we i don't know yet but i do know
this
there's almost no resistance and case in
point
you have both democrats and republicans
during
a the most divisive time we've had in in
a long time in america
i mean i think you got to go to vietnam
to to have this much divisiveness
between
and even in vietnam like if you talk to
okay the civilian populist that was was
more divide
divisive than the government was would
you agree with that statement
yes so you know in this in the city
in new york city you had construction
workers and you had hippies
and they were more they were further
apart
than the republicans and democrats were
at the time oh yeah so so but right now
it's the opposite
actually most americans are closer
together
the it's the government officials it's
the republicans and democrats that are
so
so separated and it's interesting until
you throw this
war against a virus and then all of a
sudden it's
all hands on deck we're all moving in
the same direction now there's been some
disruption now because this bill came
through and
the democrats you know the republicans
put forth the bill democrats came and
added a bunch of
uh a bunch of things that they want to
it and you so we've got a dispute going
on now but
broadly all i'm saying is we have a
situation right now where
there's no re there's very much much
much
less resistance than the government is
used to
it was kind of shocking how rapidly we
decided we were okay with that and again
i'm not saying it's not the right thing
to do i don't know
i'm not that guy i'm not the expert on
how to handle an epidemic but if you
would have asked me
a couple months ago what would it take
for whole states
to just accept being told to stay in
their homes for an indefinite period of
time i would have said
millions of people would have to be
dying in the streets otherwise no way we
would
we would accept that but it kind of goes
to show you for for as much as we like
to complain when pollsters call us up
and ask you like what do you think of
the government what do you think of the
media and all these other institutions
and we say i hate them
10 you know 5 approval rating
that i think this kind of shows like the
ease with which we handed over pretty
authoritarian powers to the government
because the media told us there was
something out there that was scary
and i'm not saying it's not scary but
that was the information we had
yeah a couple hundred people had died
shows that we actually do have a little
more faith in our institutions and we
like to pretend sometimes i think
i think the other thing that made this a
little bit of a perfect storm
is you had a lot not only did you have
alignment
between the people in the government you
had alignment between the two political
parties
and then you had this high level of
alignment between
social media and the real media
you know instead of there being you know
what
you know you instead of finding these
extreme views
hey kovid's nothing like after
you know a couple weeks ago you weren't
really allowed to say that you know
because
early on there's people going it's just
a flu who's going to get it i don't care
that got shut down real quick and all of
a sudden you had the the media
the big the big media and
the social media all aligned with
this is the plague and we better get it
under control it was interesting to see
how
the social media kind of mob
mentality that is usually mobilized for
political correctness
issues and things very quickly those
same networks got
mobilized for this for sure it was
interesting to see how that works and i
don't know if maybe that's the first
time that it's jumped
you know kind of jumped issues like that
yeah it's crazy to watch
yeah it's crazy to watch so in this
situation
going into iraq um yeah we had we had
resistance from the people against the
government move not
you know obviously it wasn't unified
resistance there was
a lot of americans that like yeah cool
in march 2003
it was either it was either pew or
gallup the biggest poll that was run at
the time in march 2003 74 percent of
americans supported the war
that's why you'll find you will not find
anybody who was of
of age at that time you said did you
support the war in 2000 no
it's like funny that's funny because
according to the polls
three out of every four people did but i
cannot find anybody who admit to it now
well you talked about the generals and
the politicians
learning bad lessons from the first gulf
war so did all of america
yeah and all of america said you know
what let's go over there and kick some
ass
and we we took the lesson and our and
our leaders
indulged this from kosovo in the first
gulf war that war
is primarily about liberation
and freedom and getting rid of tyranny
and
that's what war is primarily about when
war is not primarily about those things
war is about suffering and destruction
and death
and we let ourselves forget that because
of the 90s because of the way things
went in the 90s and um
you know we let ourselves forget that to
our detriment because if we would have
gone into the war with clearer eyes
you know we would have been more
prepared for this you know for the shock
of the violence when it hit us
yeah and uh if you go into war
thinking the the the thing that i always
say you got to go in the war with
the the will and its two wills wrapped
up in that the will to kill and the will
to die
and if you don't if you think you're
going to go into war
and you think you're not going to kill
people and by kill people i mean you're
going to kill civilians you're going to
kill kids there's going to be
you know babies murder or
killed by errant bombs and errant
machine gun fire
and there's going to be some of your
soldiers are going to lose their minds
and do some horrible things like that's
going to happen
that's going to happen so if you don't
think that's going to happen you're
wrong
you're wrong children died on that first
night of bombing you're before
anything you are wrong if you think that
and if you think you can get in and out
without taking any casualties on your
side
if you think you're not going to be
putting american flags over over caskets
you're wrong and so yes i totally agree
that when you come off of
you and it's actually a little
escalation in the in the uh
in the niceness of war because you go
from the gulf war
we took some we took some casualties in
the gulf war a lot of more friendly fire
but you know there was there was
americans killed but then you go from
that to kosovo and now you're like wait
a second
we you you track the you track the uh
trajectory
from vietnam to the gulf war and now
you're in kosovo where
hey we we can pull this off and i
guarantee there were people thinking
you know what okay we maybe maybe some
people will kill that you know
but we're gonna be all right and there
was the provide comfort
uh example where we kind of you know we
pushed the iraqi forces back and made
room for the kurds and the kurds moved
in and they
you know they created our bill as it is
right now which is a pretty nice place
to be
relatively speaking and so we we had
this idea that all you got to do is get
rid of some of the bad people
break down the bad power structures the
oppressive power structures you know
there's a i got
i love trolling my libertarian friends
and uh
i told them that you know there was a
libertarian streak
uh in the iraq war planners and they say
what what do you mean we're against war
yeah yeah you're against war that's fine
but the i the impulse the idea that all
we have to do
is go in there and get rid of saddam's
regime and then since that's not there
freedom will break out everything will
just sort of be uh
you know it'll just take over they'll
become vermont democrats just overnight
and that's not how it works um freedom
is something that exists in a hot house
environment
you know where order is enforced and
security is provided
and um you know i'm always shocked
i don't know why i would be i i wasn't
in a position to have to make these kind
of calls back then obviously and i hate
uh you know i i i always refrain from
like armchair generalship and i can't
stand people who
who do that kind of thing i get a little
resentful and frustrated where i see
civilians making decisions that seem
motivated by politics
but it seems like
across the board nobody really expected
there to be an insurgency
the civilians didn't expect it most of
the generals didn't expect it
some did um some had something to say
about it but they weren't in position
to uh you know to to really have their
voices heard
and so we had military leaders who
even then even still not expecting a
full-blown insurgency
were asking for three or four hundred
thousand troops to secure the country
and uh they were told we don't need that
many you know um
they felt that the war would be
politically more difficult to sell
if we had to tell people we're sending
you know 300 or 400 000 troops over
there
and so we end up going in with one to
130 i think something like that
and the first part of it it goes the way
first go for one right the us military
does
what it does there's one thing i want to
just
before we get too far beyond this you
know
when you talk about what you think is
going to happen is you
create a a create an opportunity for
freedom and freedom is going to break
out
that's what's going to happen what i
think
happens is you have to
establish an environment for freedom
and then it's going to take a number of
generations
for people to be able to
um own that freedom and not
and have it flourish because
you know when you've had generations so
2003 what we're talking about 20 almost
25 years
under this brutal regime you got you got
people that are
absolutely conditioned for
you know to to be to be to to fall under
the the orders of violence
that's what they're conditioned for and
and for them it's like
okay i'm on board with whatever you want
to do boss you know
yeah you know i i recently had a rose
schindler on on my podcast
and you know she was in auschwitz an
auschwitz survivor
and it was just complete compliance by
the jews
and if they got told um hey you know go
put your family in the oven you go put
your family in the oven because the
alternative was
instant death and and so how long does
it take to first
when you do that to generation upon
gender generation upon generation
they're not they don't even know what to
do when you give them freedom
so what you have to do is you have to
give them a taste
you have to start you have to you have
to get them you have to get them
addicted to freedom right you have to
let you have to protect it for them you
have to feed it to them
you have to let them eat it you have to
let them grow accustomed to the taste
you have to let them
get that taste and start to love that
taste so much
and that won't happen with the first
generation it's just not going to happen
because they still won't trust it you
have to go to the second generation
where those kids are raised like oh i
can do what i want
and i won't have my tongue cut out
and then maybe the third generation
where you've got people are like hey
you're not going to take my freedom from
me
that's what i think i think it takes
that kind of
that kind of of of nurturing of the
environment of freedom
freedom and getting people conditioned
to understand that
human beings as a human being it's a
right that you have they don't have that
attitude
their attitude isn't i have a right to
freedom that's not the attitude
and when you give them a glimpse of it
like hey like like when you see
um the troops that pushed up into
baghdad initially it was like they're
waving american flags it's like okay
and and that's why it's there like the
the
the seed is there and you know you
recently saw that in some of the
protests in hong kong and china where
like you there these people are getting
this from somewhere all in hong kong
it's pretty obvious where they're
getting it from they
they lived as free people for many many
years but so they still have some of
that
but there's a seed that exists like any
in the mind
but it's been so buried by by
fear that you have to do something
that's a long term
plan and that's why you know that's why
when you look at you know when you look
at germany and you look at japan and you
look post world war two
it was like okay we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna
i don't even know if you can say this
we're gonna impose freedom on you
for an extended period of time until
that's what you want
because human beings do they are they do
want freedom but sometimes it's just
been buried
and abused and beat down so hard
that the that it's not worth it to them
and they don't understand it
and i think one of the prerequisites to
living in a free society is you have to
have a population that trusts each other
um you know you had had sunni the sunni
minority in control in iraq for a long
time uh and the
the meshia majority and the kurds had
been abused under that system under
saddam for a long time and now you've
got to convince
the shiites who have the votes now under
democracy to just take over the
government
you got to convince them not to take
revenge on the sunnis
you got to teach them why it's a good
idea to allow the sunnis
into the government at all after
everything that they've been through
you've got to convince the sunnis to buy
into a government that's now going to be
led primarily by shiites
um and you and you gotta that takes
generations
generations you know it's generations
and and
in order to do it um
you know the first and foremost thing
you have to be able to do is you got to
provide security in the place you have
to be able to let everybody know
that look you don't have to go after the
sunnis
sunnis you don't have to worry about the
shades coming after you because daddy's
here
and um you know when we decided to go in
light and then reinforce that decision
by
canceling the first cavalry's deployment
pulling the third id back when we
replaced him with the first armor
division
um for what i believe i mean and
you know people can debate about this
and they do and they will for a long
time for what i think
were political reasons you know they
didn't they didn't they've been telling
everybody
but what about those decisions when
you're talking about
what about those so the military
all along had wanted more troops they
said we need more people to secure this
country
um eventually general franks sent comm
general
uh who was commander of iraqi forces of
our of our forces in iraq at the time he
finally bought in and he got his
subordinate generals to buy in
um to the lower amount under the
assumption that they would be reinforced
once we knew that saddam wasn't going to
use chemical weapons on us and things
like that they were going to be
reinforced and that we were going to
have the iraqi
military and police available to for
sasso operations
and just none of those things ended up
happening right you get up into
april um i think yeah and so in
we going in march 2003. real actually
let's back up a little bit where where
are you when did you get out of college
so i graduated college in the spring of
03 of 03. and you get a platoon
this is again why my life has been just
awesome i've been so blessed i i
showed up when i asked for orders to a
seal team
the guy that i asked for orders to he
when he the guy that told me you wait
when he did give me orders he gave me
orders to the next deploying seal team
right he gave me orders to the next
deploying seal team
that's a miracle right that's that's
it's a miracle it's also relationships
it's like also like you know i worked
hard when i worked for that guy i worked
hard and he he
he trusted me you know and he took care
of me he sent me to
the next deploying seal team so
it is i graduate in the spring
so june july august september
set for a set for a september deployment
so i go to seal team seven seal team
five is on deployment
they got one platoon in iraq seal team
they're coming home in september and
steel team seven is replacing them
and by the way not all of those teams
haven't just a couple platoons or
actually one platoon is scheduled to go
to iraq did you know these guys yet
who the uh you're platooned like did you
i know it's a small world it's a small
world
here's the here's the the really um
lucky things the seal team seven
commanding officer
was my executive officer
when i was at seal team 2. so again i
knew him
i had a great relationship with him we
got along great he's a great guy
and so i show up at seal team
seven in the spring that's 2003.
their workup their pre-deployment
work-up cycle for
civilians out there you know you you
train to deploy
and the deployment training ends long
before
you go on deployment it'll end six
months before and then you spend six
months doing some kind of fine tweaking
you do a you do what's called what we
used to do we don't do it anymore but
you do like an
operational readiness exercise a big
exercise to prove that you're good to go
and then you do some additional sort of
theater-based training like okay we know
we're going to this area we'll do some
focus training on that so the the main
bulk of the workup was done it was over
by the time you got there when i showed
up so
i show up and i'm there for
a matter of days and i'm walking and
actually seal team seven
had just been commissioned at the
beginning of that work up cycle
so seal team 7 is brand new we don't
even have a building yet
so we're i'm walking outside you know
we're we're kind of thrown into some ad
hoc buildings and so i show up and
the commanding officer like i said is a
guy that i work for and so he knew me
and
and and you know when you work with
someone you know him you trust him and i
had a great relationship with him and
i'm walking down the hallway so i check
in and i'm done with my check-in and
and there's one one platoon is slated to
go to war
that's you no i'm not even in a platoon
oh this is before that i'm not even in a
platoon okay okay i show up to be
ops i show up to be you know whatever
yeah
and i'm walking down the hallway uh out
the external
part of the building and i see the
commanding officer i'm like hey what's
up sir
and he goes jocko you look so angry what
are you so angry about
and just my face i said it's just my
face sir you know that he goes what can
i do to make you happy
and i said give me a one-way ticket to
iraq
and he just smiled and i was like well
that's interesting
and looking back i knew looking back he
knew what he was going to do
and what he did was
there was a weak platoon commander
and a week after i showed up at steel
team seven he fired that platoon
commander and gave me that platoon how
much time do you have to get to know
your guys
uh a couple months and uh
what kind of war do you think you're
getting into at this point i don't
care you just i i you know whatever
um you guys got information coming back
from the deployment knowing what seal
team 5 is doing
and what they're doing is dream ops for
us
direct action missions load up humvees
so now now we're thinking about humvees
load up humvees go out the middle night
take down a target grab a bad guy come
back interrogate him find out you know
what he's doing get more targets go hit
those targets it's like a dream come
true what's the op tempo here
i mean you're talking about nightly
missions like several times a week
they're doing
they're doing you know they're doing
their up tempo is high
i don't know what the specific numbers
are i would say they're probably doing
two three four targets a week this is
this is glory
this is awesome like you said there
would be seals who would spend their
entire 30-year careers
be master chiefs who would never fire a
shot in anger and these guys are taking
down targets target after target after
target
and and not only that but like i said we
we trained for
ah mission a single mission would be
would be
you know the highlight of my life right
and here's guys doing
three four five six missions
so i get put in this platoon
um and i remember as soon as i took over
the platoon
we had a training mission that night was
it that night yes it was that night
and when i took over the platoon
actually the um
the the commanding officer called me
the off-going the guy that was about to
get relieved they called him
and the platoon chief into the office
into his office
and we get in there and he goes you know
lieutenant so and so
your performance is subpar and you are
hereby relieved
and uh of and jocko
you are now taking over and
he says uh how did this go down
oh yeah and he says you know lieutenant
so and so you're dismissed
that guy walks out he says chief i know
you i know
um you know you got a you got a platoon
of good guys you had bad leadership
i should have done this earlier whatever
he said i i don't want to put words in
his mouth but he said you know
chief you got jocko and so you asked me
if i knew these guys i knew that guy
okay the platoon chief was a
buddy of mine from team one we kind of
one of the guys i grew up with the teal
team won
and yeah oh yeah and he had a he had a
good relationship with the guys
yes he could kind of slide you in yeah
yeah yeah and so
so i was excited about that and the
lpo of the sister platoon was like my
best friend for
well forever in the teams so that was
really solid too uh the
and then the task unit who ended up
being the task unit senior chief was
another like
guy that i grew up with a team one so
yeah i had some great connections
and that guy was like one of my favorite
guys ever
so yeah i'm pretty stoked man i mean i
got the commanding officer i'm super
stoked
it's just it's awesome it's awesome and
this is
this is you know this is glowing right
now ah man this is why
this is why you're in the teams right
this is why you this is why you work
hard this is why you
this is why you take care of your
teammates right because that's all this
is this is like
guys that i'd known for you know my
whole career
and they're all stoked i'm coming in
they're freaking stoked
uh so the guy the commanding officer
says
see you later to this to this he says
hey you know you're fired
and he then the chief he says chief you
know help with the transition
yeah i know you've got some good guys in
there and he says roger that he goes all
right
um i'll just you can you can go i'll
talk to jocko and then
the platoon chief looks at me and he
goes uh do you want me to tell
do you want me to tell lieutenant
so-and-so anything and i said
yeah i said tell him to get his shit out
of my desk and like that was that and i
and sure enough i you know that he left
and the commanding officer
you know we talked for a little while
and then i went down and that guy was
gone
and his shit was out of my desk and
that's when i rolled in so that night
we were doing a training mission and
i immediately went in there and i talked
to chief and i said hey who's the junior
guy who i said who's a junior guy that
like
is good to go and he goes this guy and i
go
he's gonna run the op tonight and he was
like
what do you mean i go he's he's gonna
run the op tonight he was like
are you sure and i'm like yup so he did
you know
this young junior enlisted guy starts
putting together the plan
and a couple critical things happened um
and this this junior enlisted guy ended
up being just a
great friend of mine and and very
very helpful to me because
when you build relationships with your
junior enlisted guys they can tell you
what's going on blah blah
so that night during this mission we
during this training mission and again
here we are we're going to iraq or we're
praying to go to iraq
and we were slotted there was two
platoons going to centcom
one was going to be in bahrain one was
going to be in iraq
we weren't sure who was who pretty much
the other platoon
our sister platoon and then the plan was
to rotate these two platoons
and you'd spend some time in country and
then you know then you'd go to bahrain
then you'd switch right
okay part of that was just the fair
fairy
right everyone wants to go to war hey
we're not going to let one platoon get
all the experience
so that was part of the plan so
but still we know we're going to iraq
and here we are we're going on a
training mission and it's like an
over the beach pilot rescue or something
just
not something we should have been
focused on
so we go we
come over the beach and
one of the boats like cap sizes
and engines flooded and it's just a
disaster
and luckily for me i had done a lot of
well i was you know i've been in the
teams for a while and i had done a lot
of amphibious operations more than
normal teen guy
because i had done two back-to-back arg
platoons meaning
you know an orgasm amphibious ready
group working off of a ship
like back in the day there would be one
arg platoon
for every six platoons that would be
going on a
what we call the spec ops deployment
just going to a land-based deployment
there would be one ark platoon and it
was always the bad deal and no one
wanted it
and i did two of those back to back and
the reason i did two of them back to
back is because
the odds were if you were gonna do
something real it was gonna be from the
r platoon because those were the guys
that went to somalia
and and so i was like hey i'm gonna do
those art platoons because those guys
are doing real work
for deploy at least so so uh i had done
a ton
of water work and a ton of over the
beaches more than
more than a normal seal you know does
especially at that moment in time so the
boat flips blah blah blah
i the guys are like the guys are looking
at me like hey we need to cancel like
well we need to go admin basically
go admit we got to get a vehicle down
here to get this boat
back to base because what are we gonna
do how's this gonna work and i was like
negative so i kind of just like took
over
and i said here's hey here's what we're
gonna do boom and i gave out the plan
like here's
and it's a pretty simple plan and i this
is the kind of thing i've done before
you know you get one guy with the
extended bow line he's gonna go out get
through the surf keep that thing
oriented to go through the surf everyone
else is gonna push it out
once we get in we're gonna paddle this
thing and when i said we're gonna paddle
this thing out these guys were looking
at me like i was
completely insane because you know you
got a 55 horsepower motor on there it's
a big
zodiac boat but and it's filled with
gear
so it's a pain in the ass but i know
that i can do it because i've done it
before
so but what if the key is that that they
didn't think about too much was
somebody being in the holding the bow
line of the boat and
keeping that boat oriented through the
surf and as long as that's happening
which
it's not hard to do that because you're
like basically a c anchor
so i say guys listen the bow line the
thing needs to be
you know kept forward and we'll just
paddle this thing out once we get out
there we'll
because a couple of the other boats were
fine and we just would tow it out once
we got out there
so so here we go and the guys are like
okay and i remember actually the guy
that the young
guy that i had run in the op later like
five years later he told me like when
you
so i was a guy i was like okay i
breathed my weapon in the boat put on my
fins
and took that bow on and started
swimming out and the guys got in the
boat paddled up me paddled out through
the surf zone
got it hooked up to the other boat we
towed it out we did our rendezvous c
but like five years later that young guy
said to me like when you made that call
and then we did it he's like
after that i goes i would have done
anything you ever
told me to do because i couldn't believe
that it
that you said it and then that it worked
so
that was like the first thing i first
did the first day i did the
i think it was that night i think it was
the night that that guy got fired
we did this okay and so and again i was
very lucky because
you know i had done all these arc
platoons and i was a prior enlisted guy
so i had done
multiple deployments and then i did
deployments as an officer already so i i
was very lucky that i had this
experience at the time
because i certainly was no you know
certainly no spectacular human by any
stretch
so that was that was the first night i
meet these guys and and it did you know
like you you mentioned something on one
of the earlier podcast about like
bonding together
well we did a little bit of a shitty op
and it went
sideways and we pulled it off and once
we pulled it off it was like okay
and then we we did our final preparation
and then we
went on deployment and finally jacob's
going to war
yeah i think we're up over an hour so
let's wrap it there and leave everybody
uh
with a cliffhanger right on well jacob's
heading into war
in the meantime if you want to support
this podcast
uh first of all right now you're
probably listening to this podcast on
the jocko podcast feed we're going to
set up
this podcast the thread on its own
stand-alone what is it
podcast feed it'll be its own standalone
podcast so
if you want to keep listening to it
subscribe to it and then
if you want to support this podcast you
can also check out our other podcasts
i got a podcast called jaco pondcast i
got the warrior kid podcast and i got
the grounded podcast
and daryl has a podcast which is called
martyr made
and if you want to support any of these
podcasts you can go to a place called
jockostore.com and you can get some gear
or you can go to origin main.com
and you can get some gear there that's
all i got
thanks for listening as things
unravel this is jocko and daryl
out